[Music]
in our morning rounds Medical News this
week a high-tech tool in the fight
against a deadly disease colon cancer is
the second leading cause of
cancer-related deaths in the u.s.
colonoscopy has been found to reduce the
risk of death from the disease by 70% or
more it does that by detecting cancer at
an early curable stage and by finding
and removing benign polyps before they
have time to turn into cancer but
doctors don't always find every polyp
dr. Jon LaPook is here to tell us more
John morning Anthony as a
gastroenterologist I've learned that
colon polyps can be tough to spot they
may be partly hiding behind a full or so
flat and subtle they're barely visible
to the eye it's a real problem I'm going
to tell you we're gonna show you how a
computer may help me out not just as a
doctor but as a patient getting my
screening colonoscopy at the very end ah
Skippy unit where I work and then why
you land go on health as always it
starts with the prep so here goes to
properly cleanse my colon I drank is
really not that hard and drank and drank
four liters later I was ready for my
close-up good to the last drop doctor
becomes the patient yes discomfort no
the colonoscopy will be done by dr. Mark
poor chapin chief of Gastroenterology at
nyu langone health so we're doing
something fancy-schmancy today that's
right
assisting dr. Petch a peon is the second
set of eyes a computer powered by
artificial intelligence or AI so the
good news is is that what we do really
prevents cancer but we do miss polyps
and we have to recognize that anybody
they are a recent study published in the
journal Nature biomedical engineering
found artificial intelligence was able
to detect polyps more than 90% of the
time researchers in China had fed the
computer more than 5,000 images from
colonoscopies and the computer used
those pictures to teach itself to
recognize polyps especially ones that
are hard for humans to see John you
really did a great job with the prep but
the pups that we're trying to improve
upon detection are those flat ones very
subtle blend into the background and
this is where artificial intelligence
could be most helpful
now dr. Seth gross is heading one of the
first studies exploring whether AI can
help find polyps not just in a computer
lab but in patients actually undergoing
colonoscopy how long ago did your study
begin about two months ago so really I'm
kind of one of the early people in the
study your colons at the forefront
that's good and and what did you find so
we did find a couple of polyps
all right sets I'm gonna remove it the
first polyps spotted by the AI
highlighted by a blue box was very
subtle and was removed by dr. Pugh
Chapin so what we do is we put that loop
of wire around it that was nice F they
really picked up that flat little pump
we have obtained the tissue once the
anesthesia wore off I was able to see it
for myself
hey John welcome to your colonoscopy
there was a little tiny Paula
I'm not sure who saw it first as dr.
Petch a peon withdrew the instrument he
spotted another small polyp there in his
finding it now now the AI is showing it
I was happy to hear the polyps were
totally benign and not pre-cancers but
you could see how important is that a
good prep because they were so subtle
you could easily have missed it had I
not done a good present are there any
other screening techniques on the
horizon yeah well this one is not ready
for primetime yet there are for people
who don't want to do the colonoscopy
there a stool tests looking for blood
looking for DNA and then in the future
this is very cool they're discovering
that there's a link between the certain
species of bacteria in the colon and a
propensity to get colon polyps and colon
cancer and you're gonna see we're gonna
do a web extra it's it's up there right
now I do an interview with fourth-year
medical student Rachel Sarnoff at NYU
Langone where I'm a professor after you
full disclosure and she's working in the
lab of dr. Martin Blaser and they're
looking at this possible Lincoln could
you believe it in the future possibly
doing a breath test to see do you have a
risk of or the back
[Laughter]